[Music]
hey everybody it's tuesday yeah we went
out last night man we're [ __ ] bushed
yeah
i'm yeah i'm pretty tired yeah well you
know your snoring ass woke me up again
see she's like really hard to snoring
stuff again man i was i was not starting
yes i deny
it was i told her she goes she woke up
this morning you snored all night and i
went how's your no no no not all night
you snored it like you woke me up at
like 6 30 in the morning okay like
really loud you were snoring and i was
like nah that's your imagination because
oh it's my imagination yeah he's
gaslighting yeah
i was actually thinking while i was
laying there annoyed like trying to go
back to sleep i was like maybe i should
record this
all you gotta do is roll me over
and not stop snoring i was like shut up
i was like freaking out that's not how
you handle it just roll me over well
because i mean the night before i think
i only got four or five hours of sleep
and then i was like then last night i
probably only got like three hours sleep
sleeping i'm like god damn it [ __ ]
seriously like waking me up a [ __ ]
six o'clock we need to put headphones on
you
i'm just gonna buy some earplugs no
that won't keep it out what you do is
get we'll get you some earbuds
and stream uh like the sounds of rain or
music or something that'll keep it
chilled out and then then you wouldn't
hear it
yeah i need like i love that noise
cancelling headphones i i well i have to
be like listening to something really to
false i don't really have noise i have
to have silence but i don't quite the
opposite i don't ever get that silence
actually makes me more alert noise makes
me know it's safe i think that's because
just growing up in the army and stuff
yeah growing up in military academies
and [ __ ] like oscar hearing noises is
correct you know [ __ ] a bunch of
noise and everybody talking that oh it's
safe
if it's quiet it's dangerous
because yeah i get that but it's like
i'm not and i'm not like a real light
sleeper but it's you know
i don't like noise when i'm sleeping i
don't like noise and i don't like light
i like i can't sleep in the daytime like
you can take a nap in the daytime i
can't it's it's oh man i could take it i
could take a nap on a [ __ ] flight
line with a bunch of jet engines i
[ __ ] love it yeah i love the sound of
jack i wish i could do that but i can't
i can't be up in a transport plane or in
a [ __ ] shop or eight you [ __ ] uh
one
huey [ __ ] with the whopper and all
that or the uh-60 [ __ ] they sound
very similar and just the sound of a
damn jet turbines and those [ __ ]
choppers just put me right to sleep just
[ __ ] i love it
yeah yeah i don't know what it is
well like i said i'm not i wish i could
do that but i can't great oscar perez
just called america's favorite goth
couple yeah
that's us man they were [ __ ] calling
us down the middle street last night
taking photographs of me the [ __ ] guy
that owned the bar across the street you
can you wanted me to get everybody to go
to his club
so you wanted we know that guy though we
know that guy yeah he said he knew me i
didn't know i didn't recognize the guy
yeah we talked to him all the time where
did we talk to him um it was we might
have met him at ibarr at eyebar i think
so yeah which isn't called library so he
wants me to move the crowd from my
friend's bar to his bar
no he was just saying if you wanted to
have a goth night or a new wave night
ever it's the same thing though yeah i'm
just saying that
[Laughter]
okay but we do know that and i'm just
looking at like oh dude
all right
yeah so i'm a little bit sleepy um but
you know we're talking about some
stephen king adaptation action yeah
graveyard shift yeah with [ __ ] fake
[ __ ] mane now i'm going to okay so
somebody already mentioned uh steven
mocked i guess is how you pronounce his
last name he's actually from new york
now
he's like one of the best things about
this because he's like so over the top
and he does like that main accent and
it's just like [ __ ] hilarious that's
the boss right yeah warwick and um so i
was watching like some other because i
was curious
um i know that like if you seen like pet
cemetery and stuff like the original pet
cemetery uh you know fred guin's
character who has that really strong
like main accent
um
so i was like well how accurate is that
but from what i could determine uh the
actor that played warwick in this movie
he did actually have a vocal coach who
was from that part of maine because they
did shoot this in maine actually and uh
he said that's pretty much exactly what
that dude sounded like so it was like
apparently
uh a pretty accurate
his his accent was so awesome in this
and he was like so over the top that i
don't know whose executive decision this
was but they took a bunch of his lines
from the movie and essentially made it
into like a rap song that plays over the
end credits i mean
come on and like i think the because um
this recently came i think scream
factory just did a blu-ray of this not
too long ago
and um there's like an interview with
that actor
and then he's like he was like didn't
know they were gonna do that and he just
like thought that was like a lot of
these stephen king movies
a lot of these stephen king movies were
not that good
some of them have aged kind of well
though yet
um
this one is actually one of the better
ones but it's not real serious it's kind
of horror comedy like you know it's
super cheap yeah and it's supposed to be
but it's shot real well it's real
competent it's got fun dialogue in it
and acting and crazy [ __ ]
it's totally over the top it's totally
my favorite character in it was the guy
who plays the uh was the the
exterminator yeah brad dorf yeah brad
dorf was uh he's [ __ ] awesome yeah
voice of chucky and uh he was an
exorcist three well really really you
know he got burned into my mind because
he played menta the mentette pietro yeah
that's right from [ __ ] he was in dude
as well yeah and when i and when the new
dune movie comes out i want to see who
[ __ ] pictures played by
yeah
yeah cause who doesn't i mean who
doesn't love brad dora if he's just like
a great [ __ ] character actor and like
yeah him and warwick are like easily the
best characters in this yeah i mean the
scene where the scene where brad doris
characters just plays an exterminator
and i think he's really good at exorcist
three too yeah yeah yeah just then but
um yeah so the scene where he's talking
about because he's like a vietnam
veteran and he was like talking about
being in vietnam and what the vc like
did to
the american servicemen like staking
them to the ground and like making a
little cut and then like having the rat
like crawl inside them and [ __ ] and it's
like that's a great [ __ ] scene so i
was like i was watching some like behind
the scenes stuff of this because okay i
kind of feel like
let's have a three-tier system
of stephen king adaptations
so like on the on the top tier obviously
you got your you know shinings your
miseries uh you know things like that
and then in the middle tier
you kind of got stuff like i'm trying to
think of like a maybe a middle tier
would be like pet cemetery
um
you know something like that and then
you got like super super shitty ones
i kind of feel like this falls sort of
in the middle but maybe on the end
towards shitty but
it's also kind of like fun
i had not evil dead i had not seen this
in a long time and for whatever reason
i thought when i was re-watching it i
was like actually i was like oh this is
like better than i remembered i think
that i was remembering
toby hooper's the mangler uh which was
the one with uh with robert england in
it right yeah um because they're very
similar stories i mean even the short
stories it's based on they're both in
the book night shift uh you know the
stories came out originally like in the
early 70s but then like night shift came
out in 1978
and they're both i mean the mangler was
kind of based on stephen king's own
experience when he was a college kid
working in
uh an industrial laundry uh and thinking
what if this machine got possessed by a
demon and like came to life and started
eating people and this one is set in
like a textile mill and he said that he
knew a guy that worked in a textile mill
and um and was talking i'm sorry i was
talking about how full of rats it was
and that's what gave him the idea for
this movie
or for this uh story rather now the
short story is actually really really
short
so you can see that when they adapted
this to film they really really had to
add like a bunch of [ __ ] like a bunch of
like character development and stuff
um because it's essentially just like a
monster movie right it's just you know
and like i said in the story
you know this kind of follows the story
but they added like a bunch of
extraneous uh stuff like between the
characters and everything
so what you have is this dude named um
well okay the first scene do you know
when this first came out like i don't
think it did
what year was this 1990 okay 1990. it
felt very late 80s well it was late 80s
in 90 90 1990 was very 80s people it was
yeah
i mean that's it's like i i saw too
and now this kind of gives me like a
little bit more admiration for this
movie because it could have like really
really been shitty because i think they
made this movie like super fast i mean i
think that they the movie was green
licks this was paramount
this was greenlit like in april of 1990
and they said we'll have it out by
halloween yeah and it was like so it
came out like a few days before
halloween of 1990. and for that like for
being that quick it's actually like not
bad i liked it uh although i didn't see
it when it came out had i seen this when
it came out in 1990 i probably laughed
it off
but the movies aged very well they
didn't they don't really make movies
like this anymore
if you were to see a movie like this
come out right now it would stand out
you'd like it but it would definitely
wouldn't be from a big studio it would
be an underground studio
um
it has a tone to me i was thinking it
was kind of like texas chainsaw massacre
2 or evil dead 2
or you know it was just like
it was that say they were trying to give
that same visual tone
as
a lot of the horse
horror movies of the time that kind of
kind of had over the top
gore and kind of comedy mixed into it
they tried they were trying to lighten
this gore
with a little bit of humor
probably to get it through censorship
although it didn't work because when
this movie originally came out it was
rated x because of all the glitter even
though it's not
that gory like a lot of the deaths are
kind of like you don't really see them
happen you just kind of see the
aftermath and it's yucky and squishy but
it's not
i don't think it's like super super
gorgeous this is a door of movie i think
he carries it really oh i wish he'd been
in it more right to be honest he was
he's the guy that really stood out the
most there's something about doroth
the average person doesn't really know
that dude's name i didn't know that
guy's name but every time you see him in
a movie he stands out you remember him
you remember his look
he's a very good actor he can really
pull off a [ __ ] psychotic nut
oh yeah i mean he he
he can act crazy and and you can and you
can buy it in any movie that he's in
he fit he can fit to the tone of that
movie like doom had a kind of a serious
sci-fi tone you fit to that
then he was in this other movie that
[ __ ] was like a crazy ass spit off a
[ __ ] turbinator with a big killer
robot it was like a dinosaur with
[ __ ] teeth remember that it was very
limited he was in that
oh yes oh yeah and that was the name of
that [ __ ] movie it was kind of like
a cross between a terminator
and a dinosaur an alien and it's just it
wasn't carnosaur was it it was some that
roger corman
it was a bizarre low-budget movie that
is now a classic and it had like a lot
of good [ __ ] in it
yeah and he carries the he's like one of
the main dudes
through that whole movie he's just this
psycho somebody in the comments section
might be dropping in there the movie was
very blue
it had like everything was blue filtered
yeah i remember
real and a lot of darkness and a lot of
blue and it had a lot of damage this is
the bluest robot i've ever seen it was
good yeah kind of like from the time
around matrix i think is when it came
out around like around that time
but uh somebody brought up spontaneous
combustion too which is another one we
should actually review that one because
i remember really really liking that
movie brad dwarf was in that as well and
then doroth also [ __ ] knocks it out
of the park in um exorcist three he did
a [ __ ] scene where he's in a damn
uh
[ __ ] jail cell he's [ __ ] all these
damn demonic souls [ __ ] speaking
through him and he's just [ __ ] it's
like an academy award-winning
performance man i think we was because
we did a review of that and i was kind
of like i just wish like brad dorff
would have got some kind of award for
that yeah because that was like such a
good movie yeah
he was [ __ ] great he's like this
second hollywood sleeper
the average person doesn't know his name
but they recognize him and he stands out
in every [ __ ] movie that
he should have had a lot a much
bigger fan following than he did in his
day
he's probably got a pretty good fan
following in retrospect but in his day
he wasn't he wasn't that famous yeah i
mean in horror circles he was probably
mostly because of the child's play
movies because like i said he was you
know he was uh charles lee ray right he
was the voice of chucky um you know he
was the the serial killer that
transported free internet if people
didn't know that dude's name only a
[ __ ] hardcore horror friends would
know it in dudes louie also brought up
that he was in uh one floor of the
cuckoo's nest which i had totaled yeah i
had totally forgotten about that
so yeah it's like
i feel like he's yeah he was um i feel
like he's always he's never like the
star of the movie he's like a supporting
actor he's always like a supporting
actor but it's like like you said
anytime he's in a movie he's always like
the best thing at it yeah you know what
i mean and he was like one of the best
things out of the [ __ ] original dune
movie yeah uh because there's just
something i don't know there's just like
something
he was a human computer they were like
angolas that were brought back to life
they were like the dead brought back to
life
mind wiped and given all these [ __ ]
drugs that allowed them to learn things
and they were kind of like living human
computers that you could buy as a slave
because they were the undead that's in
the dune world they were like that yeah
the mentats because it was like against
their laws to have computers because
they took over in a prior era it's
[ __ ] great movie i can't wait for
that [ __ ] to come out and pider was like
was a [ __ ] very rare and expensive
mentat because he was [ __ ] evil
and a mentat was not supposed to be evil
he was very evil
and you know they're not supposed to be
yeah he was like into the pleasures of
the flesh and [ __ ] he had been corrupted
you know and they were conditioned to
where they weren't supposed to be
corrupted but the harkonnens had them
baron vladimir harcona and had one and
he was like an exotic evil computer
living computer
badass idea
somebody brought up that thinner was
also a really good underrated stephen
king i just watched that again like not
too long ago and that was also better
than i remembered this one was better
than i remembered i have to watch the
mangler again because like i said these
two are kind of similar and i think they
maybe came out like within a few years
of each other um so i was thinking when
i watched this movie i was thinking i
was confusing some scenes with the
mangler but yeah so what happens in this
one and you know what's cool about this
not only obviously they actually i think
there was like a fairly large studio
that was talking about remaking this
like up until 2014 i think they were
throwing around the idea of remaking it
but i don't think that would have been
so cool because it would have just been
it would have just been all cgi rats and
i don't think that that would have been
too awesome because they actually use
real rats for this and uh you know and
also where they shot it like i said they
shot it in maine
um and they shot it in a real
old textile mill
so some of the stuff
like i think like the the last scene
with like the big
rat bat monsters thing like lair with
all the bones and stuff in it i think
some of that was a matte painting
um if i'm remembering correctly but all
of the [ __ ] you see like in the mill
that's all a real textile mill like it
had been there since 1821 or something
like that i don't think it was open
anymore um but
so so it really gives it it really gives
the movie this really grimy
yucky because like everything is like
dirty and filthy and wet
and just
it just feels like this nastiness and
there's all these like [ __ ] little
rats like looking at him stuff but i
have to say like the opening scene
with like the guy that's working the
cotton picker machine and you know
there's the little rats like come up to
watch them and stuff like hey man what
you doing you know it was like sitting
on the bags and everything and he's like
given this lecture like um you know have
you done your homework today or
something like that and then he's like
you didn't that means so he picks up a
rat and he throws it like into the
picker machine at that point i was like
okay i'm sorry i'm team rat
i kind of wanted the rats to kill
everybody they did uh they did kill a
lot of people but the thing about it
though i think that in the original
short story which has been a while since
i read it
i think in the original short story a
lot of the [ __ ] does happen like warwick
is a character he's you know he's like
the foreman and he's like this crazy
bastard or whatever and uh you know this
one guy comes there gets a job and it's
you know fourth of july weekend they're
like we need to clean out this basement
like so we can put some offices down
there or whatever and no one's been down
there for for ages and it's like just
it's rat infested
so that happens and then they find a sub
basement and then there's like a big
like a big huge [ __ ] rat down there
but for whatever reason in the movie
they made it like a big rat bat hybrid
yeah it didn't make sense which didn't
really make sense but honestly i thought
the monster was like really good i
thought it was really well done like the
practical effect was really well done i
don't know why they did it they were
like well it's not just gonna be just a
big rat that's not gonna be impressive
it's gonna be a rat it's gonna have big
wings
because it can like enfold people which
i thought that was kind of cool even
though if you're thinking about it it
doesn't really make any sense that there
would be like this because where is
where is this creature going to fly to
yeah i mean it would be flying around
yeah because it lives underground thank
you trey
uh yeah the poster for this movie
reminded me of the one from my bloody
valentine yeah i thought that too and it
was just kind of like it's weird because
the poster
doesn't really if you just saw the
poster back in 1990 and you hadn't read
the short story and you just see this
like this skeleton or the skull with
like a hard hat on and it's called
graveyard shift so you're assuming it's
going to be like workers at night and
stuff which it is but maybe zombies or
something yeah like i don't think it
gives any impression that it's about um
it's a monster movie or that it's about
like rats killing people
um unless you'd read the story
should have been just brad dorf on the
cover
[Laughter]
but see the people were like they were
so mean to the rats in the movie that i
was kind of because the rats were kind
of cute you know
like sitting up there like looking at
everybody like hey man we just you know
we just want to like live like just like
throwing them into the picker machine
and i was just kind of like man the rats
should kill every one of you [ __ ]
which they uh which they actually do end
up doing actually had i seen this in
1990 like i said i think i may have said
this already i probably wouldn't have
[ __ ] really liked it all that much
but
it's aged very well you watch it now and
it's in retrospect it's good
it's good like if you were to see a
brand new movie like this if you were to
see it come out right now you'd like it
yeah it'd be fun i mean like i said i
don't know i mean i guess it was
supposed to be like comedic as well
because it does have like that kind of
tone to it but i think it helps because
the cheesiness factor is is very high
because everyone's just kind of because
brad dorf is like over the top but in
like the most awesome way possible
steven mock's character is just
completely over the top with that
[ __ ] crazy-ass main accent
and um he's just like so good at it and
he's just like so evil like for no
reason whatsoever is just like he's you
know it's like they go down in the
basement he just starts like [ __ ]
killing people leaving a bunch like that
he's like oh well whatever the
production quality was pretty good
it was and it was
the colors the color filters and stuff
that they used on it we're trying to
give it kind of candy colored so there
it's it's trying to be
in in
in the in the movie motif of the 90s and
the 80s this is
it's trying to portray itself basically
as a comic book movie
it's not supposed to be real a lot of
stuff happens it is not realism
yeah it's just you're just supposed to
watch it and enjoy it like it's a comic
book movie
and it's just a lot of tales from a
crypt or yeah and it just kind of like i
mean like i said a lot of the you know
the characters over the top which is
great but there's also kind of like this
whole like
funny bullying storyline type of thing
like when the um the guy like john hall
uh that is the character's name he's
played by uh
what's the guy's name david andrews yeah
um so when he comes there and gets a job
at the mill like all of the dudes at the
mill are just like picking at least like
third grade [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's just like hey if it did rent hey
you know what i mean it's just like i
don't really know why but that i kind of
feel like that happens a lot in stephen
king stories where it's just like these
[ __ ] in town that are just like
picking on people for no reason
whatsoever is trey's asking how long it
was in theaters
probably not very long i think that it
only cost i think it cost 10 million to
make and maybe only made like 12 million
back
um
so it kind of came and went in this era
there were a lot of good movies making a
lot of money in theater it was number
one the weekend it came out because that
was halloween weekend but then i don't
know but then after that it just kind of
like trailed off that would have been
good enough if it was number one for
that weekend then they would have
replaced it with another movie that was
making money because you have to
remember 1990 was the [ __ ] era of
damn blockbuster so when this thing
ended up in on vhs it made a lot of
money on vhs just kids renting it
yeah and it's funny because i think that
stephen king
he came to the set one day when they
were when they were shooting it and um i
think that he would he either watched
like some of the dailies or something
like that and i think he said to the
director um this'll do great on video
yeah like i don't know if like i guess
he it sounded like he like throwing
shade maybe because it's like this is
going to do well in the theaters but
it's not but maybe yeah maybe that's not
already because that was a futuristic
that was the futuristic sales um
strategy in 1990
if you went direct to to video
you could still make a lot of money all
right and if the production quality was
low you'd make a lot of profit that was
a decent
way of doing it but it but that movie
would not have clout
if it had a theatrical release and then
went to to vhs even better
because it had
street cred of being of having a
theatrical release yeah that it was a
real movie
but a lot of those movies and this is
probably one of them a lot of those
horror movies were made to do just
exactly that be in a theater for a week
or so
but the idea was to get it out on vhs
and [ __ ] make money on it now they
had all kinds of contractual [ __ ] like a
lot of times they had to wait six months
before it could go but that was all part
of the plan
yeah mr roboto says was the book better
tom and jenny uh it's always better it's
not wasn't a book it was actually a
really short story um yeah it's in it's
in night shift which came out in 1978
which i think has like some of his best
short stories ever but yeah it's in
there the story is way better um but you
can tell like the movie like expanded
out on it but what i was gonna say was
that
the reason that this came out that week
and like i said the reason they put it
into production so quickly was because
late 80s early 90s that was like a big
they were adapting like stephen king out
the [ __ ] ass man like every time like
whatever stephen king wrote they're like
yeah we need an adaptation of that like
to tweet so it's so when somebody comes
to them with a script hey i've adapted
graveyard shift like the stephen king
they're like okay do it have it out by
halloween because we want a stephen king
adaptation out so they so it was almost
kind of like because the dude that wrote
the screenplay for this this is what i
heard john esposito who actually
wasn't really um
well known then he's since gone on like
he's even like written some episodes of
the new creep show and [ __ ] like that so
he's gone on to do like a lot more
horror [ __ ] um
but he just wrote an adaptation of it
like no one asked him to or anything
like that he just wrote it and it just
happened that he knew somebody that
um because i think the guy that directed
this ralph s singleton who i don't know
if this was his first movie but he
mostly worked in tv like he did like
cagney and lacy and [ __ ] like that and
um so he knew somebody at paramount and
was like hey you want a stephen king
adaptation this kid wrote one um you
know that like unauthorized and so then
they were like okay we'll put it into
production so like i said stephen king
seemed excited about it at first but
then when he saw it he didn't like it
but i guess he didn't hate it enough to
like take his name off it because every
single place i see this now is stephen
king's graveyard shift
so it wasn't like a lawnmower man
situation where he sued to have his name
taken off and honestly rightfully so
because that movie has absolutely
nothing [ __ ] to do with the short
story that it's based on so
i you know i can see why he did that
this is a fairly you know this is a
decent adaptation i think i mean it's
not one of the worst ones i kind of
wanted to do
it's not christine either
yeah but like i said it's not like top
tier it's not like dead zone or anything
like that you know like some of the
[ __ ] brilliant ones right yeah i
didn't even fire starter was damn good
too yeah
honestly it's like i know a lot of
people and we've kind of gone into this
a little bit too but this is something
that i can probably talk about all day
is that
you know i i know a lot of people so
it's like so many shitty adaptations of
stephen king's stuff but there's not i
mean there's really a lot of good ones
yeah that a lot of people forget it's
just that they made so many
that actually liked dark half and a lot
of people didn't like that but i liked
it i did as well yeah i like star cat
yeah the [ __ ] bad guy come out of the
[ __ ] novels he was from what jasper
county or jones county mississippi and i
was going yeah yeah okay
he had his old [ __ ]
highly toned son of a [ __ ] on the back
of his [ __ ] car
[ __ ] that's right yeah
yeah his car was highly toned son of a
[ __ ] yeah so i like i also likes the
dark yeah he was a [ __ ] killer
[ __ ]
he was a killer [ __ ] rockabilly
redneck yeah pretty cool yeah wasn't i
think john tarturo played him i think he
was like and i love i love john
yeah uh yeah oscar perez said christine
was great i feel like when people bring
up awesome
stephen king adaptations hardly anybody
brings up christine and christine is so
good and then so was the made for tv
salem's lot from back in the 70s
best king adaptation
i don't know
anything wrong with the [ __ ] tv
salem's lot the shining or misery
one thing wrong with the tv salem's lot
is that mr barlow didn't speak
and in the movie he spoke
you made it in the book he spoke in the
book yeah yes i'm saying in the book he
spoke in the in the in the made for tv i
kind of preferred that he didn't talk
i thought it was scary there's a real
good scene in the book
yeah i know
[ __ ] it challenges that priest to a
duel
over the
child remember about it yeah
and a battle of faith and the priest
lost [ __ ] [ __ ] mr parlor killed
his ass
killed his ass and the rest of them too
yeah
yeah somebody brought up secret window
i've actually wanted to do secret window
uh recently because i think that is on
where the [ __ ] did i see that now this
stephen king's graveyard shift is on
hulu
and i think hulu also has
sleepwalkers which
i haven't seen it a long time but i
remember that being one of the really
shitty stephen king adaptations but i
could be misremembering because like i
said
that was one with all the cats right i
kind of feel like that was one with all
the cats
but i'm trying to like think of some
really shitty ones i mean obviously
everybody brings up like shitty stephen
king adaptations like [ __ ] um uh what
do you call it the one that was uh based
on trucks
the [ __ ] uh maximum overdrive um and
that is a shitty movie but it's so
shitty that it's all the way it goes all
the way around it becomes awesome again
uh just because it's like so shitty i
haven't seen it so you would you would
probably love it yeah you would love
maximum overdrive it's just like it's
one of those
uh worst ones lawnmower man that's what
i mean and honestly like i said that's
lawn mower man yeah i would call that an
adaptation and name only because that
had [ __ ] all to do with the short story
oh i want to say stand by me was a
really good one too that was [ __ ]
brilliant that was based on a novella
called the body
i mean so i mean like i'm saying it's
just it seems like there's been a lot of
good ones yeah and of course you know
the best one we didn't even match the
best one with the shiny
i did i said the shining and or misery
or carrie see there's a there's a bunch
of good ones the dead zone kerry was
really good god damn so there are a lot
of good there are a lot of good ones
langleiers wasn't too good from what i
remember
okay i'm gonna put that one that one's
in kind of the shitty that was bad which
that was like a really good story and
that was a shame because they kind of
they kind of whiffed that yeah i mean i
haven't seen all the stephen king
adaptations because let's be fair there
are like so many
but
people always forget fire starter man
and fire starter was [ __ ] great it
was up there with like dead zone i like
yeah i really liked fire starter as well
and honestly like mike flanagan has made
some good [ __ ] he made like [ __ ]
gerald's game and um did he make 1922 or
was that somebody else and that i kind
of feel like a lot of stephen king's
stuff
i think that his more psychological
horror works better in a film
than his more horror horror usually
silver bullet it wasn't that bad that
was delightful that's pretty good that
had gary busey and his gary busey is
juicy in the [ __ ] out it was so [ __ ]
do you see honey
do you see the [ __ ] out of that damn
that was silver bullet was good because
it was a horror movie and it was kind of
like a similar tone to like gremlins
where it's kids an uncle and a monster
you know kind and
actually no it was probably more closer
to like fright night
yeah more like fright night not as good
as friday night but i mean it's kind of
like friday night very few very few
movies are as good as friday night let's
be honest yeah but um but yeah i have a
soft spot for silver bullet not bad that
one's cheesy too
but it's cheesy in a fun way you know
what i'm saying um but yeah like and
lately like i said they've made some
good stephen king adaptations i feel
like terrible they did a terrible job of
[ __ ] the dark tower man poor idris
elvis well see that needs a series
because come on how are they going to
cram all of that it has to be a series
it's got to be [ __ ] really long and
detailed it has to be
it has to be pretty much verbatim by the
book yeah i mean it just happened
because that's like a whole like [ __ ]
universe and the lead man has to be as
described in the [ __ ] book in the
book he is described as clint eastwood
he's clint eastwood he's like a parallel
universe version of [ __ ] clint
eastwood so you have to have a tall
skinny [ __ ] white guy with a long
coat and it
you know [ __ ] if you could get
eastwood to do it'd be great he's far
too old but if you could have got he's
starting to look like a mummy these days
but if you were to get eastwood into his
50s or his 60s even he could have done
it
that might have been uh kind of
interesting yeah i have to say i never
really got into stephen king's more
fantasy stuff yeah um i liked eyes of
the dragon which was kind of like a
fairy tale-ish kind of thing
but i read like the first of the dark
tower series and then i read
uh the talisman yeah that was a great
one and that's him and peter
my favorite genre of his uh honestly my
favorite stuff of stephen king's i like
his like early
horror [ __ ] you know what i mean like
all all of his early books pretty much
were good i love his short stories but i
feel like he's at his best when he does
psychological horror sarah just showed
up she's apologizing she wasn't able to
change her name it's okay
that's okay she had she was her she was
busy up in germany eating all that damn
peanut butter yeah yeah yeah sorry
making peanut butter pie yeah mmm peanut
butter pie
yeah sandra said the green mile was good
yeah the green mile was actually good
see so like i said they have made like a
lot of really good ones there's a lot of
really good ones um you know and like i
said the i feel like uh dolores
claiborne was great
um you know that was a great book too i
remember and okay i've been wanting to
rewatch this
i remember
um they made like a tv mini series of
rose red
because i remember really liking that
book now did he write the book first or
did they make the tv series like and
then he wrote the novelization from i
can't remember how that went because i
remember it was like a big event like
when it came out of tv that was like in
the early 2000s i want to say and i
remember that being pretty good
shawshank redemption that's updated yeah
shawshank redemption again this is like
i kind of feel like other than his early
[ __ ]
like you know christine and you know the
shining which is like a ghost story and
stuff i kind of feel like his better
stuff and the stuff that makes better
adaptations is stuff that's just more
psychological like that the best one or
just best one everybody knows is the
shining okay kubrick that's it yeah all
right but actually for me the most
watchable
the one where you just watch it and you
like it it's just fun to watch is
christine i think that's the mo isn't
the most watchable one yeah that's john
carpenter john carpenter yeah
i mean and like i said i feel like
that's a really that's one a lot of
people don't bring up when they're
talking about the good stephen king
attitude maybe right underneath that
would be would have been carrie
yeah real close real close yeah like i
mean there's so many good ones like i
said [ __ ] misery was great
so many the dead zone is great yeah
it's hard yeah yeah salem's lot was
great and then yeah salem's live
yeah but man i'm still just kind of lean
towards and running man that's right
ronnie man yeah running man with stephen
king that was stephen king adaptation
also
i i just kind of
i forgot that running man was stephen
king that [ __ ] wrote everything
he wrote everything that was kind of
[ __ ] weird though
probably running man that's the arnold
schwarzenegger running man right yeah
that's where i forgot yeah it was an
adaptation yeah very loose a loose
adaptation because the real original one
was kind of more more kind of like uh
[ __ ] the ones with
what's the one where the where the girls
[ __ ]
the girl what was the name songbird or
[ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] were
they're holding like gladiatorial games
between the cities and [ __ ] oh there was
a whole bunch series of them the hunger
games the hunger games was kind of more
like hunger games yeah really what the
original story was about hunger games
that's right i remember the story being
like pretty serious like the novella
yeah but the problem look
now i'm gonna start getting in the
[ __ ] arnie all right
that was a decent arnold schwarzenegger
movie but it was really missing
something there was no real action in it
an action movie without any action
that's a weird concept
if you go back and watch
the running man you never really see
very much combat
yeah people get killed and you're not
really sure how they got killed
you see sub-zero he got edited to death
yeah
they edited all pretty much all of the
violence out of it
it was still kind of a good story but
when you watch it it's not a lot
there's no real action in the [ __ ]
movie they edited all the violence out i
still like that movie but they needed to
have a [ __ ]
nc 17 version of that but i i bet you
maybe they never even shot it because
they might not have it could be that
they never shot any of the real action
movies it it promised a lot like oh man
this is a gladiatorial [ __ ]
battle to the death but i think if i
remember correctly
arnold did not want to [ __ ] come
across as a villain and in a certain way
that character kind of was a villain in
a way or you thought he was for half the
movie and then it turns out he's not and
so i kind of think arnie didn't want to
be on screen murdering anybody
that might have been what it was yeah mr
roboto says running is action tom
jumping is action yeah
yeah
which means now this is an action show
but you guys are old enough to remember
the [ __ ] context of the time
the movie that changed everything the
movie that even changed video games was
[ __ ] commando all right and commando
was basically a video game big [ __ ]
muscular dude
running from one fight and killing all
kinds of dudes with all kinds of guns to
the next one and there's even boss
fights in it and everything and then it
ends with a [ __ ] boss fight
and he's leveling up as he's going
getting different weapons and [ __ ] it's
like watching him and it has a [ __ ]
great soundtrack it's like you're
listening to this and a lot of video
games after that movie
were built upon
the edit of [ __ ] commando all right
so commandos set the bar high
but i think even [ __ ] arnie had to
try to back off of that because he
wasn't all that famous when he made that
movie you know he started to want to be
a hero all the [ __ ] time yeah even
though he's a great bad guy yeah and so
like oscar brought up the terminator
he's [ __ ] great and he knew that yeah
he knew that but he didn't want to be
trying to be a bad but like i said i get
it because if you're an actor you want a
long career if you get typecasted
villains that's it then you're never a
headliner right it's kind of like you
know you're the one that always gets
your ass kicked at the end you always
get killed and [ __ ] yeah and then
your value starts going down and down in
hollywood you know well you know he's
just the guy that we have we show up we
kill him
[Laughter]
so he was correct about some of that
[ __ ] but some of that [ __ ] for artistic
purposes
should not have involved him being 100
good guy
yeah yeah i mean oh i wanted to say too
that uh other good stephen king
adaptations would be uh i just thought
of some anthologies cat's eye and
creepshow oh yeah yeah yeah i forgot
about that because creepshow even though
i mean that's what based on his stories
and cat's eye
had three of his short stories adapted
and that was actually pretty decent i
think somebody sent us that didn't they
because we did a review of it a little
while so i always have like a lot of
affection for that yeah so now i'm
it's like i say that there's three tiers
of like stephen king adaptations but
it's like most of the ones i'm thinking
of are good ones you know what i mean
yeah they're all they're all um
they're all agreeing with me the [ __ ]
commando was a video game pretty much it
was it was like duke nukem kinda yeah or
it was just you know back in those days
a video game was a scrolling platformer
that had levels
you know what i mean
and it ended with a boss fight and
that's the way that movie is set up yeah
it ends with boss fights starting off
with what was his name scully i lied and
dropped you know [ __ ]
the bosses get harder and harder as it
goes
yeah
yeah uh apt pupils i mean yeah you know
what i don't think i saw i loved that
story but i don't think they did make a
movie adaptation of it but i don't think
i ever saw it yeah um yeah room 1408
that's another good one with john cusack
uh that was also great i'd say samuel l
jackson was in that too
uh yeah that was a really good so like i
said all i can think of is good ones so
now i'm trying to think of
stephen king stories or novels that
haven't been adapted which that might be
hard to think of because everyone i can
think of has been adapted at some point
even if it was just like a made-for-tv
movie or something um
which ones haven't been adapted but
should be adapted
or
now i'm trying to like think of
something hold on though i got two
things i gotta jump on people brought up
a couple in the comments brought up a
couple things and said terminator
actually was a theoretical bad guy
because it was a robot all right that's
true and then and then uh somebody else
said well by the time total recall came
out he didn't seem to care about killing
people
the problem is is that's more
theoretical [ __ ]
because if you pay close attention to
total recall he never went to mars it's
all in it it's all it was all in his
mind
it's all this is my mind
um
he was still back at recall and they
were programming him to think that he
was a secret agent on bars he didn't
kill anybody
he had the embolism
thing that they talked about
yeah because they brought that up in the
middle they told him that he would
totally believe it
all right yeah and it could be that the
embolism thing was part of the program
that swallowing the red pill or whatever
swallowing that pill would have [ __ ]
made him not believe it so now he
believed it was true so everything that
recall promised him
[ __ ] that he would have in his
adventure is fulfilled in the movie that
he would be the hero an alien
civilizations and that he would have an
affair with the [ __ ] the woman of his
choice
on a secret age yeah
it was all fake it was all part of
recall total recall total recall means
just oh it's all your [ __ ] memories
it's just you're just totally
remembering that [ __ ] it didn't really
happen
yeah so he didn't kill you buddy uh did
king make dr sleep yeah he did write
that book um
honestly i liked the movie better than i
liked the book isn't that weird i don't
usually say that um has anybody done an
adaptation of
bag of bones because i really i don't
know i have like a lot of affection for
that novel because i remember it just
being like kind of like a ghost story
and i'm really into those
but
i mean i'm sure somebody must have made
an adaptation of it because like i said
all of his [ __ ] has been adapted and he
has that thing too where
you can actually pay him a dollar
and
get the rights to one of his short
stories like he has like a huge list of
them um and you can make like it's for
film students like you're not really
allowed to make any money off the movie
obviously but you can make a film
adaptation of it as long as you're not
making money off it like i said it's for
film students um but yeah he has a thing
i think it's called dollar babies where
you can do that and he has like a bunch
of his short stories on there that you
can adapt which i thought was kind of
cool but um yes mr roboto i assure you
he did not go to mars
[Laughter]
he was a lowly construction worker yeah
there is a bag of bones movie see
every single [ __ ] thing that i can
think of god damn it everything's been
adapted
i can't think of a single thing that
hasn't been adapted in some format or
another yeah even though that [ __ ] is
written for it i wonder how many pages
how many words he's written over his
entire career yeah
yeah yeah mr robot is going to go on
time i think he did go to mars
because i got into this a little slow
remember that i got into this
my buddy my buddy i call him little
swole he [ __ ] he's a big arnold he
loves that movie we both loved that
movie
but he was like no man he went and
[ __ ] every [ __ ] thing that he
could pull up out of that movie that
proved that he went there's something
else in there to disprove that it
happened yeah i remember you guys having
yeah wouldn't have that no he did not go
he was the only construction worker he
paid for those memories and and recall
gave him exactly what he wanted and it
stated in the beginning of the movie
yeah yeah and he believed it 100
so did you because you're seeing it
but no he stayed he didn't go to mars
they show the girl
they show the girl he ends up meeting
later on in the [ __ ] computer program
when he's selecting
what the girl should look like with his
sexual preferences in the very beginning
they show that girl yeah and that's who
that's what he means later yeah i mean
i'm pretty sure the intention was to
show that it was all
yeah man it's my understanding i haven't
read the original uh dick's story that
that it's based on evidently it's r it
it's based on real ambiguous [ __ ] and
that's the way philip dicks [ __ ]
wrote stuff
but no he phil's dick was about
he took a lot of drugs he liked
psychedelics and
he was about [ __ ] with your mind
uh and i'm all about it yeah and philip
dicks believed in mind control and
government mind control and he was
almost kind of an alex jones of his day
oh he said he was a real trip but no it
was in your mind
it was in
all this co-hague and stuff and this and
that he's actually a secret agent his
wife was a secret agent and in the dream
he killed his wife because that whether
he wasn't his wife which that gave him
permission to have the new girlfriend on
mars who's another secret agent and [ __ ]
no man no dude come on
he was a construction worker
who paid for that [ __ ]
yeah cause that was kind of the whole
point of the company yeah they told him
that [ __ ] he would believe it 100 so
they gave him all this deniability no we
never did the process on you this is you
know
no no no you're not back no this dude
offering you the pill [ __ ] no he's not
you know he's not there you know or
whatever this isn't an illusion or
whatever you know that kind of [ __ ]
sandra's talking about the long walk um
that she would like to see that as a
movie i could have sworn i heard
somebody was working on a movie
adaptation of that and i would also like
to see
an adaptation of that that would
actually be really good um
i would also like to see an adaptation
of the stephen king novel that i just
read
for my uh tomes of tarot show which was
revival which i think came out in 2014
and i don't and i hadn't heard of it
previous to that because like i said the
[ __ ] writes so much that i can't like
even keep up um but that book was
actually really good and i think that
would make a decent movie it almost it
gave me kind of like a um
something wicked this way comes kind of
vibe um a little bit so i kind of feel
like that might be cool as well oh
speaking of which
i just saw well speaking of just
something i remembered i just saw the
another trailer for candyman today and
that is coming to theaters in 10 days
august 27th so and it looks
really good
um i hope it's going to be really good
so i kind of maybe want to go to the
theater and see it all right and we'll
see how it is like i said it's august
27th i think it starts but yeah i just
saw the
trailer i was cause remember we saw the
trailer for it like two years ago and
then it kept getting pushed back and so
they have a new trailer now and it
actually looks uh looks pretty kick-ass
but uh you know uh yeah needful things
was good i i actually kind of want to do
a review of that too because um
i think it's on shutter or something i
saw it on somewhere the other day and i
was like oh yeah man that's a pretty
decent movie
jenny don't say candy man four more
times
he's going to come out the [ __ ]
laptop screen all right so we're going
to
mr roboto go ahead and watch [ __ ]
total recall again you'll see it he
didn't go
[Laughter]
you're you're you're on you go on
vacation with him through his [ __ ]
mind in this [ __ ] fantasy it's a
mind-blowing it's a it's a mind [ __ ]
it didn't happen
all right so we're gonna wrap this up
now because seriously we have not eaten
a single thing all day long and i'm
starving i could even hear your tummy
growling at a couple of points when i
was talking
uh so yeah all right so we will be back
tomorrow
evening for the side tracks show
[ __ ] man we're gonna have to drink again
i mean you don't have to i'm just saying
it makes it more fun uh but yeah so how
much booze left well we could just have
them we can have a little bit or we can
go to the store tomorrow because i'm not
going to the store today [ __ ] that i'm
going i'm going to finish up what i'm
doing and then i'm going to go to sleep
this is what i'm gonna do uh but yeah so
thanks everybody for dropping by talking
about stephen king and uh we will see
you guys tomorrow evening at 5 p.m
eastern for the side tracks show
see you guys later bye